wie kann das weitergehen mit diesem
Krieg keine Kristallkugel haben wir da
alle nicht aber es gibt Menschen die
sich hauptberuflich mit solchen Fragen
beschäftigen und klug analysieren in
eine von ihnen ist Claudia major sie
leitet die Abteilung sicher die
Forschungsabteilung Sicherheitspolitik
an der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
und Abend Frau major guten Abend wenn
wir jetzt sehen wie Putin eskaliert also
da hunderttausende Soldaten einzieht und
offenbar auch recht schnell wohl an die
Front schickt was sagt uns das darüber
was er vorhat
ich glaube die mobil machen müssen wir
doch noch mal anders einordnen weil er
wird zwar Truppen bereitstellen können
aber nicht sofort und das werden auch
keine sehr hochwertigen Truppen sein er
muss die erst einbeziehen er muss die
rekrutieren er muss sie ausrüsten er
muss sie ausbilden das geht nicht super
schnell auch weil die Strukturen dafür
nicht mehr da sind und auch die
Ausbilder fehlen zum Beispiel und selbst
wenn die einmal an der Front sind sind
ja die dauerhaften Probleme der
russischen Armee schlechte
Führungsfähigkeit logistikprobleme
moralprobleme die sind ja nicht weg das
heißt er wird Truppen kriegen aber
wahrscheinlich erst so Anfang 23 und es
werden keine sehr kampfabroben keine
sehr hochwertigen Truppen sein wir
sollten das aber trotzdem nicht klein
reden denn das Signal was er sendet ist
er ist bereit diesen Konflikt in die
Länge zu ziehen und zwar so lange dass
er hoffentlich länger durchhält oder er
glaubt er könnte länger durchhalten als
die westlichen Staaten also setzte im
Prinzip darauf dass hierzulande die
Leute dann oder auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern quasi in die Knie
gehen wenn dann doch die Gasrechnung und
die Stromrechnungen sehr hoch werden und
das ist zu sozialen Verwerfungen gibt
entspricht ja auch immer von diesen
verweichlichten Demokratien auf der dann
setzt in dem Fall das ist in der Tat die
Sorge dass er glaubt dass er diesen
Konflikt länger durchstehen kann als die
westlichen Staaten also er hofft dass
die westliche Unterstützung bröckelt
wenn bei uns die Energiepreise hochgehen
es möglicherweise zu sozialen Fragen
kommt wenn noch mal neue nukleare
Drohungen kommen wir können davon
ausgehen dass Russland noch mal oder das
Putin noch mal nuklear drohen wird wenn
man möglicherweise Bilder sieht über
erfolgreiche scheinreferenten wenn es
auch weitere Berichte gibt wie schwierig
die humanitäre Lage in der Ukraine ist
weil Russland eben die zivile
Infrastruktur vom Krankenhaus bis zum
Wasserwerk platt gemacht hat das heißt
der hofft dass in den westlichen Staaten
die Unterstützung bröckelt und die
Ukraine ist auf die finanzielle und auf
die militärische Unterstützung durch die
westlichen Staaten angewiesen das heißt
er hofft dass er länger durchhält als
die westlichen Staaten und das sollte
man im Kopf haben und ganz stark dagegen
handeln
zum Beispiel mit panzalieferungen die
aber ja die Bundesregierung nicht will
ja ich glaube es ist ein ganzes Paket
das ist die Frage der finanziellen
Unterstützung die Ukraine als Staat muss
weiter bestehen das heißt sie muss vom
Lehrer Gehalt bis zum Wasserwerk alles
am Laufen halten also die finanzielle
Unterstützung die humanitäre
Unterstützung weil viele Städte zerstört
sind das sind Winter geht und die Frage
ist kann man heizen gibt es Wasser gibt
es Strom aber es ist natürlich auch die
militärische Unterstützung denn die
Frage ist wenn die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzt werden soll ihre Gebiete wieder
zu befreien und wir sehen anhand der
folterberichte aus Issum oder auch aus
Butcher wie notwendig das ist dann
braucht sie eine systematische
langfristige gesicherte Unterstützung
durch die westlichen Staaten an Material
also das heißt auch Schützenpanzer oder
Panzer wenn sie wirklich Gebiete
zurückerobern soll und nicht nur
verteidigen aber da befürchtet ja
offenbar zumindest die deutsche
Bundesregierung dass das zu einer
Eskalation führen könnte also dass dann
da irgendwelche imaginären roten Linien
bei Putin überschritten werden und es
fällt ja zumindest auf dass er und jetzt
zuletzt auch der Außenminister lavrov
noch mal betonten dass die Russland
angegriffen werden wenigsten seine
Existenz bedroht werde das sind ja auch
so ein das ist ja auch so ein wording
wie ist denn der nuklear Doktrin der
Russen steht also ist dieser diese
Drohung nicht doch vielleicht auch
ernster zu nehmen also diese Drohung ist
total verstörend und sie ist total
unverantwortlich sie ist aber wenn man
ehrlich ist auch nicht neu vor Beginn
des Krieges und seit Beginn des Krieges
hat Russland regelmäßig
nuklear gedroht und hat regelmäßig
versucht uns damit nuklear zu erpressen
das heißt den westlichen Staaten in
ihrem Handeln einzuschränken Russland
macht das wahrscheinlich mit zwei Zielen
das eine ist den westlichen Staaten zu
sagen haltet euch raus interveniert
nicht direkt im Krieg das haben die
westlichen Staaten auch nicht gemacht
und das zweite Ziel ist in den
westlichen Öffentlichkeiten also bei uns
für Angst zu sorgen für Sorge vor eine
möglichen Atomwaffeneinsatz zu sorgen so
dass wir die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine reduzieren also nicht so viel
Waffen liefern und auch sonst
vorsichtiger sind aber und das ist mir
ganz wichtig man muss auch sagen dass
das bislang rhetorische Drohungen sind
es gab keine militärische Ableitung also
die Waffen nicht verlegt worden da hat
sich sagen nichts bewegt und man muss
auch sagen dass ein solcher Einsatz für
Russland einen geringen militärischen
Nutzen bringen würde aber sehr hohe
Kosten hätte weil sowohl die USA als
auch die NATO gesagt haben dass sie dann
ihre Rolle im Krieg fundamental
überdenken würden das heißt Russland
wird wahrscheinlich als Paare ja
dastehen und der Westen wurde stärker
eingreifen wenn man das so als so eine
Art Nervenkrieg bezeichnet ist natürlich
wichtig dass die Europäer zusammenhalten
und wird heute in Italien gewählt man
weiß nicht noch nicht wie es ausgeht
aber es war ja ein Bündnis angetreten
bei dem unter anderem Saline dabei ist
der mit Putin T-Shirts auf dem Roten
Platz posierte oder die
Berlusconi-Partei ballusconi hatte dann
nach der Annektion der Krim auch nichts
besseres zu tun als ich damit Putin
ablichten zu lassen wie sehen Sie das
wie sehen sie diese Wahl in der in der
Bedeutung ich glaube das ist die
übergeordnete Frage wie lange Europa
geschlossen bleiben kann Europa und auch
transatlantisch mit den USA das heißt
schaffen wir es als westliche Staaten
diese politische Geschlossenheit
bewahren die ja erst die Voraussetzung
ist die Ukraine langfristig zu
unterstützen oder lassen wir uns
auseinander dividieren und das ist der
Faktor die Hausaufgabe für alle
europäischen Hauptstädte Frau major ich
danke für das Gespräch sehr gerne